I broke a prop firm world record with
two and a half million dollars in one
payout, and I'm about to show you
exactly how. Most traders think it's
about strategy or psychology, which is
why most traders never make it to a
payout. Today, I'm pulling back the
curtains about how prop firms actually
work. Now, again, most traders think
it's about finding the perfect strategy
or mastering psychology, but that's why
most traders never see that payout. And
today, I'm going to break down the
rules, so how prop firms actually work,
the evaluation structure, and which
account type to choose. And in all these
examples, I'm going to use Apex Trader
Funding, which is the firm that I did
hit that two and a half million dollar
record payout with. Then, I'm going to
break down the math, so the numbers
behind winning at prop firms. And
honestly, without this, no strategy in
the world is going to save you. Then
finally, I'm going to get into the
execution, so the exact strategy and
approach that I used to consistently
pull payouts from prop firms and hit
that two and a half million dollar
record payout. So, firstly, let's talk
about the different account types. So,
with Apex Trader Funding, we have
intraday trailing and end-of-day
trailing. Now, in the next slide, I'm
going to break down both of those, but
let's go over the different account
sizes and the different rules. So,
starting with the 25K account size, so
the minimum days to pass is one, meaning
you guys can pass these evaluations in
one day. Now, I don't recommend doing
this if you're tight on money, but if
you really wanted to, you could full
port these accounts and try and pass
them in one or two trades. Again, not
recommended. Now, position sizing, we
have our max contracts over here. So, on
the 25K account, you're allowed to trade
four minis or 40 micros. Again, this is
something that I don't recommend you do.
You do not need to trade with all of
this size. Your profit target's $1,500
and your max drawdown is $1,000, giving
you a one and a half ratio from the
drawdown to the profit target. Now, as
you go up in account sizes, you can see
that the drawdown you're given a little
bit more, but it's a little bit harder
to hit these profit targets. So, in
these examples, for the 25K account,
they give you $1,000 to make 1,500, so
$500 more than the drawdown. In the 50K
account, they give you
meaning there's 3,000, meaning there's
difference between the drawdown and the
profit target. In the 100K account, it's
almost a two times, so they give you
$3,000, but you have to make $6,000 to
pass. In the 150K account, they give you
$4,000, but you have to make $9,000 to
pass. Now, when I went on that run with
Apex, I did choose the 150Ks. They were
harder to pass, but they gave me a
little bit more leeway when it came to
trading because it gave me a bigger
drawdown. So, just keep this in mind, a
really good sweet spot is the 50Ks
because they give you a decent amount of
drawdown, and it's not so hard to hit
the profit target. So, as you can see
down here, the cost of these accounts
are a little bit more as you go up in
size. And over here, I just have some
frequently asked questions that I pulled
directly from Apex's website. Now, can I
pass the evaluation in a day? Yes,
there's no minimum trading day
requirements, meaning you could pass in
one day. Is there a daily loss limit?
So, the intraday evaluation does not
have a daily loss limit, meaning if you
wanted to risk the $1,000 on one day,
let's say if you have a $250 loss, you
could continue trading if you really
wanted to until you hit these drawdown
limits. Does the trailing threshold
reset each day? No, unfortunately, it
doesn't. So, if you start out with a
$1,000 of drawdown on your first day,
and you take a $250 loss, you only have
$750 to trade with the following days.
Can I extend my 30-day access period?
So, this cost is for a 30-day cycle, and
you have 30 calendar days to pass. If
you don't pass within that 30 calendar
days, the accounts reset to zero, and
you have to start all over again. Now,
getting into the end of day accounts,
the drawdowns are the same, the targets
are the same. The only difference really
is how the drawdown is calculated, and
they cost a little bit more money. So,
if you can see down here, the intraday
trailing drawdown is a little bit less
expensive than the end of day trailing
drawdown accounts. So, what is end of
day trailing versus intraday trailing
drawdown? Now, this choice alone can
affect how you're going to trade the
markets. So, with end of day trailing
drawdown, the threshold recalculates at
the market close only. So, if you were
down $250 in the middle of the day, but
ended the day break even or profitable,
your end of day trailing drawdown does
not get hit. Meaning, if you were down
$250 in the middle of the day, but end
of the day break even or profitable, for
the following day, you have $1,000 of
drawdown again. Now, these end of day
accounts do have daily loss limits, but
they pause your trading and it doesn't
fail your account. With intraday
trailing drawdown, however, it gets
calculated based on your unrealized gain
or loss. Meaning, if you were up $250 in
a trade and it comes back and stops you
out at break even, it will negatively
impact your drawdown by $250. So, on a
25K account, if you have $1,000 of
drawdown and your trade goes $250 in a
profit and it comes and stops you out at
break even, you now only have $750 for
that next day. Now, this account type is
a little bit trickier because you have
to take profits early and you have to
manage your stops more aggressively. So,
with that being said, let's get into the
math behind how prop firms work, but
before I do, if you guys want the best
discounts at Apex, use code J at
checkout. I'll leave a link down in the
description. Now, let's get into the
math of why 93% of traders fail prop
firm challenges. And this isn't meant to
scare you, it's to show you exactly what
you're up against so you can avoid the
same mistakes that everyone else makes.
So, with the evaluations, the pass rate
is an abysmal 5 to 10%. 7% of those
traders ever reach a payout. And 65% of
traders fail in their first week. 70%
lose their funded account before month
three. So, essentially, out of 1,000
traders who start an evaluation, only
350 people make it past week one. So,
only 140 of those pass an eval and only
70 get to a payout, meaning less than
10%. And the biggest reasons why most
traders fail is number one, oversizing
and no risk management. Number two is
blowing your drawdown in the first three
days. Three, revenge trading after loss.
Four, trading without a plan or strategy
hopping. Five is not understanding the
rules. I can't tell you how many guys I
see online that just don't read the
rules of these different prop firms. And
number six is treating the eval like a
lottery ticket. Now, each one of these
is causing a leak in your trading system
and what triggers this is going to be
different for every single one of you.
So, you have to figure out what is
triggering you and causing you to
oversize or causing you to revenge trade
or causing you to trade without a plan.
Let's say if you get angry or frustrated
and don't know how to take a loss on the
day and you can't step away from the
charts, all of those are going to
trigger some of these mistakes that you
see of why most traders fail. Now,
taking all of this into account, the
biggest reason why most traders fail
isn't because of your strategy, it's
because you're not managing the drawdown
properly. So, here's how I protect my
drawdown on every single account and
it's very simple. So many people tell
you to risk one, two, or even 3% of your
account size on a specific trade, but
you have to approach these prop accounts
way differently. Because let's say if
you have a $3,000 max drawdown on a 100k
account, that's only 3%. So, if you're
risking 1% per trade, that's only giving
you three attempts to pass that account.
Now, the higher your risk per trade, the
higher your risk of ruin. Meaning you're
exposing yourself to variance. If your
strategy only wins on 40 to 50% of your
trades, if you risk the full drawdown,
you have a 50/50 chance or a 60/40
chance that you're going to blow the
account on one trade. Now, if you want
to take this slow and you want to treat
this like a professional, what I do is
take the drawdown amount and I divide it
by 20 trades. Why do I use 20 trades?
Because it gives me room for error. I
know with my strategy and my system that
I'm never going to lose 20 trades in a
row. However, I have lost five, six,
even seven trades in a row. So, again,
this gives you a safety net. The smaller
the risk per trade, the lower your risk
of ruin. So, at $150 a trade, meaning
you take the max drawdown divided by
however many trades you want to give
yourself as an attempt on this specific
eval, it gives you a max risk per trade
of $150. Now, again, going back to the
account sizes, you should not be trading
with this much size per trade, okay?
They give you 40 micros or four minis on
a 25k account. How long do you think
it's going to take if you put on four
minis to blow a thousand dollars? A
couple ticks against you and you're
blown out. So again, you have to trade
small enough to allow variance and the
numbers to pan out. So down here, your
risk of ruin comparison at $150 per
trade, your risk of ruin is very low,
but as you increase the size, your risk
of ruin goes up and the bigger chance
you have of blowing that account. Now
again, divide your drawdown into 20
trade. That's typically what I do. $150
max risk per trade means I could
probably put on one to two micros just
to get past that drawdown. And when
you're in the funded stage, once you get
past the drawdown, the drawdown locks.
So on a 100k account, as soon as you hit
$103,000,
the intraday trailing stops. And now all
of a sudden you have $3,000 to trade
with and you don't have to worry about
unrealized profit or loss. So my
recommendation is to always take it slow
when you get funded, get the trailing
drawdown to stop, and then you have more
freedom to manage your trades
effectively. Another rule that I give
myself to manage my drawdown periods is
one to two trades per day maximum. So
you don't need 10 trades, you just need
one to two high probability setups. And
maybe that means you're not trading
every single day either. You also want
to have a daily stop out. Now on the end
of day trailing drawdown accounts, they
automatically give you a daily stop out.
These are non-negotiable. So again, if I
lose two trades in a row, I'm done.
There's no exceptions. It prevents one
bad day from blowing me out of the water
and becoming a catastrophic drawdown. So
just walk away, right? Tomorrow is a new
session. The markets are always going to
be there. Now, emotional trigger
controls, this got cut off a little bit,
but this is extremely important. My
emotional triggers were one of the
biggest hurdles that I had to face in
order to become profitable because I
wasn't willing to accept that I was
impatient, I got angry, I got
frustrated, and I made those mistakes.
So if you aren't already, make sure you
start writing down your emotions while
you journal during the session, not
after the session, so you can be present
in your mindset and understand the
mistakes that you're making on a
day-to-day basis. All right, now that
you understand the rules and the math
behind how I was able to become
consistently profitable with prop firms,
here's the execution framework. Now,
this is not about finding the perfect
entry, it's about finding
high-probability setups that protect
your drawdown. So, the core principle is
that you're trading only A+ setups that
align with the daily draw on liquidity.
You only need one or two trades a day to
become profitable. Again, your goal is
not to make as much money as possible in
day one, it's to be consistent and
protect your drawdown for the long term.
The keys to staying consistent, same
risk every trade. Again, if you're given
$150 risk per trade, you should not be
sizing up on losses or sizing up on
winners. Try to keep the risk the same
every single trade. Now, this fixed
position size, it removes a lot of the
emotion that you have because now you're
just playing a game of numbers. Two,
trade less, not more. Again, one to two
A+ setups a day beats 10 mediocre ones.
And overtrading is the number one habit
that kills consistency. Not only does
overtrading kill your P&L, but it
creates more work when it comes time to
journal, which is my key number three is
to journal every trade. It's way easier
to sit down at the end of the day and
journal one to two trades and learn from
those rather than taking 10 trades and
now you don't want to journal anything.
Why? Because it's too much work at the
end of the day. Key number four is walk
away when the rules say so. So, if
you've hit your daily stop or if you've
revenge traded or you've done something
dumb and you've broken your rules, step
away and come back fresh the next day.
Now, step one here is going to be
identifying the daily bias. So, where is
price likely to draw to? We're going to
look at our previous day high and low
sweeps, unfilled fair value gaps, swing
points, and the higher time frame order
flow. As you guys can see on Nasdaq
currently, as you can see on Nasdaq
currently, we're on a massive bullish
trend. And when we see price displacing
to the upside aggressively, I tend to
avoid taking any bearish positions. Why?
Because when the market is trending
higher on the higher time frame, a lot
of those bearish trades that you see on
the lower time frame are going to fail.
Number two is wait for a swing failure
pattern. So, what we're looking for is
price to push beyond a key swing high or
low, fail to hold, and reverse back
through the level and close. Meaning, if
I'm bullish, I want to see a swing low
being broken, a reversal, and a closure
back above that low. Now, that failed
breakout is your signal. It shows you
that traders are trapped on the wrong
side, and it confirms the direction.
Step number three is you're going to
enter on the lower timeframe. So, after
confirmation, you're going to drop down
to a lower timeframe for your entry. You
could use whatever entry model you want,
a fair value gap, a breaker order block,
fib retracement, whatever entry model
suits you. Because the key here is
waiting for that swing failure pattern
in step number two. The entry is just
how you're going to enter and manage
your stop loss. But, the higher
timeframe idea that the market is going
to go higher is already there. So, any
bullish entry model should tend to work
out more often than not. Now, you're
going to manage your risk and not your
targets. Just because you have a
specific target in mind does not mean
that you're going to hold the full
target. Managing risk means that maybe
you have time exits. So, you're going to
exit a partial before lunchtime or when
the market's already expanded, or you're
going to trail your stop loss
aggressively. And maybe you're going to
scale into a trade that's working out in
your favor. So, here we have a short
example, and we're going to go top-down
from the daily to the 1-hour, and then
the results of it. So, here we can see
that we've taken out all this buy-side
liquidity. We have this swing failure
pattern, and we have a new daily swing
high, and the daily candle closes
bearish. So, our daily bias for the next
day is what? Bearish. Now, we have our
higher timeframe bias. We're going to
drop down to the lower timeframe for our
entry. So, on the 1-hour, price swept
out the swing high, but failed to hold,
and it closed back below. Now, a fair
value gap was left behind on the move
down, which provided the entry zone. So,
if we zoom in here, we have the previous
day, which was very bearish. You can see
that here. And then, at the market open,
we have a swing failure pattern into a
bearish fair value gap. So, on the
closure of this next 1-hour candle, we
have a swing failure pattern. And what
we're trying to do is time an entry on
the next hour. So, we can see that we
possibly enter here, put our stop loss
above the previous hourly high, and
we're targeting this previous swing low.
Why? Because on a higher time frame,
we're bearish. Again, the stop goes
above the swing failure high. Now,
here's the result. Guys can see here
that this market took a couple hours to
get down to the target, but eventually
it did. Now, let's go over a long
example. So, again, we're going to start
on our higher time frame. What is the
bias here? It's bullish. So, price swept
liquidity below the January swing low,
printed a swing failure pattern, and
reversed with a bullish engulfing
candle. Now, the bullish draw on
liquidity is confirmed, and we're
possibly going to target the highs up
here. So, here we can see multiple swing
low points being taken out, and what
we're looking for is a closure back
above. So, once we have this closure
back above, the following days should be
bullish. Now, on this specific day, we
have a bullish engulfing candle. So, for
the following 24 hours, we're expecting
more bullish price action. Now, let's
drop down to the one hour for an entry.
Inside of the one hour time frame, we
have more confirmation that the market
is still bullish. So, price swept the
swing low and failed to hold. So, we
have another swing failure pattern in
line with the higher time frame swing
failure pattern, and a bullish engulfing
candle. So, at the closure of this
bullish engulfing candle, we can enter a
position here as a little bit of a
retracement, put our stop loss below the
swing failure low, and we're just going
to aim for a three to one. Now, here's
the result of that specific trade.
Again, it takes time to get there.
Sometimes, you have to manage this trade
through the rollover period, because a
lot of futures prop firms will not allow
you to hold overnight. What we can do is
close the trade before the rollover and
just reopen it with the same exact risk.
And it's essentially as if you didn't
exit the trade in the first place, as
long as it doesn't gap up during that
rollover period. You now have a simple
and proven approach to passing prop
firms, but chances are this isn't the
only reason you still aren't profitable.
I know this because I struggled for 10
years before I became profitable, which
is why I created the Trading Apprentice.
This is not your average trading
Discord. It's direct access to me, a
verified seven-figure trader and world
record holder, to teach you everything
I've learned in the last 15 years. I'll
leave the link to apply down in the
description, but I want to be clear, I
don't work with just anyone. If the link
still works, there are slots left.
Otherwise, you can join the wait list.
As always, don't forget to like and
subscribe, and I'll see you guys in the
next one.